like even if i like you know brought up
the whole debate of like you know
japanese people love 2d [ __ ] and when
you put a real person into it
then it becomes more interactive it's
they'll be like i still why not just
show the real face and i'm like valid
argument parents
well that's not how it works i mean i
work like that yeah my parents don't
understand anime period so trying to
explain youtubers to them is just like a
whole another level it's like anime but
real focus my parents haven't asked me
yet luckily
i had this the other i had this the
other day when i went back home to
england and i had to explain to like my
family members like what v-tubers was
right and there was just like
so many
levels i had to explain to even like
come close to like introducing the idea
of vg yeah yeah because they didn't know
what streamers how streamers made money
they didn't know what youtubers would so
i need to i needed to like basically
explain the internet before i could even
like start explaining what vg was up
iron mouse told me a really [ __ ]
funny story that her mom her mum so her
mom is like doesn't understand it either
right yeah and uh because because mouse
is like really sick and you know can't
leave her house and i can't do anything
really and
um her mom thought that everyone who was
a v tuber was also in the same scene
was sick and there's just something so
wholesome about that that i thought oh
i don't know why that just like warmed
my heart in a weird way where your mum
was like is everyone the same
no mom
but thanks for asking
it's a nice scent yeah that was really
awesome how did you explain to your
parents when you started getting into v
tubing um i didn't explain to them
what did you tell them
they know now right yeah they don't know
but um
they will never understand so i just
didn't
and my daddy
um
still doesn't understand anything about
what i do i think does he does he keep
asking you to get like a normal job
um no he didn't okay
but um
he like
what the [ __ ] is like
v tubing and why does everyone pay money
to you
know
a solid argument
um
see they're they're on step two of
parent step one step one is the the
period where they're like you should you
should go get a real job yeah and then
step and then step two is where they've
just given up on that and they just
start to question what you do yeah
cause like i remember when i first quit
to do youtube and patreon was like my
main form of revenue my parents oh my
gosh yeah and then i had to explain to
my parents what patreon was and why why
that was basically my monthly salary
yeah so i'm just like yeah so just
people pay me to uh be me and uh do
things that i did already and they're
like no but what are they paying you for
like um
to just to be me and they're like no no
no no but what are you selling to them
like i'm not saying
i feel like you're explaining it pretty
bad yeah
just existing yeah it's like welfare
really but just uh specific for me i
mean isn't that just what youtube ad
revenue is welfare for youtube yeah
we're all fair for youtube a bit too
generous i think the world fairs
oh my god
very generous welfare
when you're starting off it's like
welfare right yeah yeah so going back to
the language thing are you surprised how
much of a potential there was in an
international audience because v tubing
until like the last few years was very
much a japanese thing it was a japanese
idea and i think like
a lot of your like a lot of your content
made it so that it was more accessible
to people in the west so were you
surprised at all with like the rise of
youtubing just globally i was really
surprised i thought like um
just like my daddy had some allergies
about these internet v tubing things
it was the same for those um
western uh viewers to have like um this
anime
well
out of my avatar avatar thing talking to
you like that maybe
it will like feel weird but i thought it
was really
one thing and i just wanted to introduce
to them there's something like this and
it's really fun if you don't like it
it's fine but just
just take a peek at it
oh and they took a peek at it all right
it's kind of crazy how much it blew up
in
the west i guess really yeah
almost overnight it feels like it blew
up was it was it overwhelming at the
time of course it was [ __ ]
i thought it was overwhelming when it
was happening in the japanese audience
as well that's true true they're like
why are all these english people coming
in what the [ __ ] it's like you only have
to worry about you know one small island
nation worrying about it and now you
have the entire world looking at you
yeah scary i mean it's kind of like
anime itself right where a lot of it was
originally just you know everyone
thought that only japan cared about
anime yeah and now it's getting to a
point where it's just becoming the
mainstream cool thing for all your kids
to be watching anime and like you're
bullied now for not watching anime and
now yeah like i i remember my kids have
it easy
yeah like i remember have like i had
like a monthly like discord hangouts
where um some of the members who are in
my discord group have been like watching
me for like
like seven to ten years and it's like
that that already blows my mind but
every so often we uh get someone new
into the group and normally you know
everyone introduced myself by saying
their favorite anime and you know saying
you know their wife or husbando and like
in the past few years it used to always
be you know anime waifu or you know
anime has bandos yeah but now every
every time someone new comes in it's
like always v tubers now yeah my
favorite
videos
now yeah yeah there's v tubers uh a lot
of them getting figures a lot of them
getting androids
which is pretty crazy right like that's
i think if you'd have said that like two
years ago everyone would be like no well
i mean i think he's an eye right yeah i
was like when kizna i started blowing up
and she got like her own
figure and stuff like that yeah so yeah
i was like i was like whoa what the [ __ ]
this is so weird they're like figures
yeah like when the figures came out was
nuts and now it's just like pretty
normal yeah super normal yeah
when's your when's your video coming
okay so
eventually you're the newcomer as a
viewer you can sell two things
i'm figuring
[Music]
i was wondering where you're going
i was like figuring nendoroids
i was like figuring superb
thankfully we haven't gotten to that
point i don't think yet but uh because
you could sell there is you could sell
yourself right as an nft
stop stop is that what is that what
they're doing we like we don't need we
don't need this idea to be you know
i i i just kind of clock out whenever i
see the nft now i just stopped looking i
don't read any article i don't want to
look at it just just yeah you're the one
that keeps bringing it up on the show
okay one more one more thing before i
stop talking about nft have you seen the
clip of keanu laughing at nfts
no it's so good there's this clip where
this guy talks to keanu reeves about
nfts and he just starts giggling
he's like you mentioned something about
replicating it
just the idea of like gotcha nft is just
like that that scares me so much don't
tell them that girl yeah you just gave
him an idea now
every gaijin company is like all i'm
saying is garcia companies don't make
enough money
i think they're making it i think they
made more than enough that was a
sarcastic joke right there just just
just so just so that was like
got into [ __ ] fate and their
quarterly revenue winner yeah exactly